je sais que le changement peut faire
peur mais il peut aussi nous remplir de
joie
[Musique]
en route vers notre nouvelle vie
Robert
[Musique]
pour ton anniversaire une baguette à
souhaits personne ne dit les choses
comme tout le monde a un Dalia pas si on
peut faire autrement
tout le reste semble facile est-il plus
simple de vivre en dalacia et bien ce
n'est pas ce que je dirais nous avons
des dragons des
ogres et des rébellions l'an dernier
tout notre royaume a été avalé par une
baleine
ça n'a rien d'un royaumement chanté
c'est un royaume en chantier loin de mes
amis
je suis en retard je travaille loin
d'ici maintenant vous allez monter dans
ce train encore et encore et encore et
encore et encore et encore et vous
déciderez
comme vous le voyez Gisèle tous nos
voisins ont leur place ici quand vous
aurez trouvé la vôtre vous ferez de
monroville tout ce que vous souhaiterez
je souhaitais vivre une vie de contes de
fées
trouver le grand amour ce n'est pas
toujours si facile
ma coiffure est trop
pas pris trop décolleté
cette ville est censée devenir un conte
de fées
plus rien ne sera quand votre foi
je suis pas un chat je suis pas un chat
je suis pas un méchant mais qu'est-ce
qui se passe tu as sans doute besoin que
je te remets à ta place elle me manque
tu ne peux pas
du sel et c'est jeter un sort nous
devons empêcher ça ou tout ce qui fait
embarrasser amour vous n'avez plus
aucune chance de dessouetter ce souhait
Gisèle
tu sais bien qu'il ne peut y avoir
qu'une méchante dans cette ville
vous a-t-il la rente inc
onsciente mais il arrante